welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king and mike floria are looking at some
of the biggest stories in the nfl and
one of the biggest stories and one of
the most surprising stories the afc east
technically still in play with two weeks
left and the patriots hosting the
buffalo bills on saturday an nfl network
game her friend mike tarico will be
handling the play-by-play along with
hall of famer kurt warner
uh handling the the uh analysis
did the bills have a shot in this game
we saw how close it was in buffalo 16 to
10 they harassed and harangued the
patriots the patriots emerged with the
victory can the patriots pull off a
sweep or can the bills
pull even with the patriots with one
week to play
i think the bills are going to win this
game with one proviso okay if josh allen
doesn't turn it over now that's a big
proviso because josh allen is a feast or
famine guy a lot of weeks in the nfl uh
but if he plays an efficient game and
doesn't turn it over i think the buffalo
bills will win this game not just play a
close game but mike you know one of the
sad things about this is you have to go
down to you know the real deep tie
breakers uh and and it is it's a common
game tiebreaker to determine
uh
you know if there's a tie at the end of
the year who's gonna win it and so and
unfortunately or fortunately whatever
you know the patriots win that
tiebreaker so new england's got to go oh
and two in buffalo two and oh down the
stretch and with the miami dolphins
coming to foxborough on a frosty uh
christmas week game uh that could mean a
lot to the patriots i i don't see the
patriots going 0-2 down the stretch but
i love this game and i think for the
first time basically in a generation
we're talking about a legitimate chance
of seeing a change in the garden the afc
east
hey and what a motivation it will be for
former patriots assistant brian flores
whose staff has other connections back
to new england for them to go in there
and spark that changing of the guard
because even though the dolphins don't
benefit
from it directly i think they benefit
from someone other than the patriots
winning the division uh so i think
they'll be highly motivated to go in
there and win that game week 17 if the
patriots lose the bills on saturday and
here's the thing about the bills that
should be encouraging win or lose on
saturday they are six and one on the
road this year so when it's time to hit
the road for the playoffs which they
undoubtedly will be doing unless they do
win the division
that's good news for them they've played
well away from new era stadium they're
only four and three at home and six and
one on the road so that gives them maybe
a little bit more of a chance when they
go into new england a place where they
play every year and they get an
opportunity to uh beat the patriots and
at least pull even with one week to play
that in and of itself even if the
patriots win the division pete the fact
that they'd have to win it on a
tiebreaker is
virtually inconceivable given how
dominant they've been they've been and
it raises real concerns about the
patriots in 2020 even if tom brady
sticks around
look here's the way i look at
where the buffalo bills are right now
it's likely that they're going to be the
fifth seed uh you know in the in the afc
so if they're the fifth seed in the afc
they'd have an impossible road to the
super bowl you know imagine having to
beat deshawn watson uh lamar jackson and
patrick mahomes maybe all on the road to
get to the super bowl but i could
definitely see them winning at least one
game in january and mike i go back to
last year the most painful game of mike
florio's 2018 season and that is buffalo
going into minnesota and killing the
vikings
and that showed me that this coach is
different
that this uh quarterback the new
quarterback is different and this team
is different this is a tough minded
football team and they do not mind going
into foxborough i can tell you that
hey let me tell you one trick they may
have up their sleeves for the playoffs
if not sooner unleashing josh allen as a
runner they've been very careful with
him this year now one of the reasons
they've been careful with him is he got
blown up by the patriots in week four
when he was running the ball but look at
last year he had multiple games over 100
yards he had two others with more than
90. he can move the ball with his legs
and when you're into single elimination
mode peter you add that to what you've
been doing all year long all of a sudden
you may have something even more special
with the bills
this game this weekend and i will be
watching every snap of them in the
postseason they are the most fascinating
team in my opinion down the stretch
we'll have more pftot on yahoo sports
throughout the season have a great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports